sur l'île de la réunion les côtes sont
découpées de façon abrupte des trottoirs
rocheuses succèdent aux falaises le
sable noir issu de la dégradation de la
roche est peu présent ces roches soumise
aux assauts du vent balayés en
permanence par les embruns desséchée par
le soleil constituent cependant des
endroits où certaines plantes ont trouvé
un lieu propice à leur développement
dans les fissures qui lézardent le long
de la paroi de basalte des plantes
s'épanouissent déployant leurs feuilles
dans une chaleur étouffante
ces plantes sont des salles y est elle
s'installe dès qu'elles le peuvent dans
les moindres interstices et créent des
petites populations dès qu'une surface
le leur permet l'intérêt d'avoir réussi
les transformations indispensables à une
vie dans ces conditions donnent un
avantage certain en effet peu de plantes
les concurrence sur ce terrain extrême
elles peuvent donc se développer à leur
aise et profiter des quelques maigres
ressources à leur portée les feuilles
poussant bouquet au sommet des tiges
vert clair presque fluorescentes
regardons maintenant les feuilles
elles sont spatule et épaisse
pustuleux zh
possédant des poils sur les deux faces
dans tes au sommet les fines gouttes
d'eau salée sont capturés par les
nombreux petits poils mais au lieu de
tuer la plante elle lui profite
voici donc son secret le sel est retenue
par les tissus de la plante et l'eau
traverse la feuille il suffit d'en
goûter une pour comprendre qu'elle est
capable de filtrer le sel de l'eau elles
sont acidulées et salé et était
autrefois consommée par les habitants
entre le mois de juillet le mois de
septembre les bouquets de fleurs
apparaissent à la cime des branches
elles sont serrées les unes contre les
autres rondes blanche avec des pistil
jaune
le choeur porte les fleurs mâles avec
des étamines couverte de pollen tandis
que les fleurs femelles sont constitués
de petits cornets qu'au rejet de nectar
qui entoure ce si
les insectes sont nombreux à se régaler
du nectar produit par les fleurs et les
parcours ne semblant pas gêner plus que
la plante par la présence du sel
les fleurs ainsi féconder fans et se
dessèchent
les petites graines vont tomber ou être
emportés par le vent et trouveront sans
nul doute un coin de rochers ou germées
encore une fois la magie opère et la
nature nous prouve que les mystères du
chemin de la vie son riche de nombreuses
stratégies